this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I asked my job because I said they came
they basically said to me you're not
sick you just don't really want to work
and it didn't make a difference that I
would sleep all night and get up and
take a 10-minute shower we'd have to
sleep another hour but I had to drive an
hour to have to work and that couldn't
get out the car and they look at you and
they say there's nothing wrong with you
you don't look sick right years old
therefore you don't want to work so we
lost all the resources so I ended up at
Grady in a time where I was between jobs
when no one else was going to hire me
and I had no more resources so Grady has
always been for me not only just a
safety net but just the support of the
doctors that are here and meeting dr.
Lim and you know he is a life singla you
know really takes its time to understand
what's going on with you not just
clinically but really emotionally and
how the disease meshes together so that
your part and be proactive in your
healing and you'll recommend you to go
to support groups and he'll try
different medications and he's you know
very much into the research end of Lucas
and so he knows what he's doing I came
in to the Georgia lupus registry and it
was so good to finally understand that
somebody is actually tracking the
numbers of people because for me when I
hear people about lupus the first thing
they say somebody mama died of lupus my
cousin thought Luke was my grandmother
died so everything was associated with
death and I'm like okay here you are
having this disease where everybody
believes that its death then how do we
change that so the research that he does
really does help us to look at the
numbers and the data of actually people
that are living with this disease and
then we can do more research and have
more drugs and so it's exciting it
really is and yes so I found my passion
when I met dr. Lim and we began dialogue
in and you start telling me some
interesting things about the Grady to
George Lucas registry and then he
invited me to be a part of the team so
in that sense I work with lupus research
and community liaison with the doctors I
get
no what's going on behind the scenes I
can help patients understand what's
really going on because you hear a lot
of diseases but you don't ever hear
about the lupus research so I'm able to
connect them and said guys this is
what's really going on this is what
they're working on but this is what
needs to happen and by the same time I'm
actually getting helped and healed
because of all of the information that
I'm around so it's not that lupus has
become my life it's just one factor in
my life but it's a major factor that I
am so glad that this is what it took for
me to be able to reach other people the
one disease so it is one voice one
person
you
the preceding program is
Emory University